big deal [ __ ] entourage
dude this would be great for my career i
gotta get this my manager calls me hey
they got a part
this party's gonna run over about three
episodes uh they wanna see you
what
i remember
i go oh my god
i go read
i got [ __ ] sheila sheila jaffe she
[ __ ] up i go read for sheila she
[ __ ] up oh my god sheila and i i come
back oh i got a call back
they called me back i call my manager
dave
they want me to come back oh my god
that's a call back that's good dude you
got this you [ __ ] right i got it i'm
getting big i'm [ __ ] confident
i walk in the room
bow wow's in the room oh i knew it was
that part i didn't want to say because i
don't know [ __ ] taller than you or
not what the [ __ ] is bob i'm doing here
right now i never forget it i walk in
the room bow head on the big jersey and
a do-rag what the [ __ ] about while doing
here
this part i don't know you had a weird
jersey nobody told me where jersey i
kind of like a regular t-shirt
i got a i got like a regular t-shirt god
i wish i was like the [ __ ] part is
like a fun part this guy's like loud
he's got like a little bravado to him
yeah he's got a script he's got a thing
are you ready for him
yeah i remember
i remember
going in
i [ __ ] kill
i kill
i leave
right all right man see i don't know
about why at the time all right see you
guys later i'm walking out
i don't get i'm i'm probably on the
third step walking out
walks in the room i hear hey
the [ __ ] is going on in there
is he reading i stay on the step for a
second they're dying they're going
they're going through the roof
what the [ __ ] is happening in there
he was reading with kevin
what's happening with dylan or kevin
uh all right well i don't get a call
back
and i keep calling and i just remember
watching entourage
and seeing bow wow do the scene
and i was like i lost the part the
[ __ ] bawa
you know bow a very talented guy but at
the time this hurt me i've lost many
parts to many people well just give me a
second because this is a big moment for
me to say [ __ ] you to you this is this
is a this is a
it's a big i set you up for so i can
tell you how i really feel here because
i think we're gonna win an emmy for this
episode
it's like therapy for you
but i'll never forget i'll never forget
i'm gonna be able to get one tear if not
bring the makeup into bring it in just
blow
but i said that to say you know uh at
the time you know the things that you
think matter the most of course they end
up being a gift and a curse a shot at
the bow wow because yeah he obviously
killed it and you know when i watched it
he was very good in the part i actually
saw that he did [ __ ] that i didn't even
do in the audition but at the time
that show was
there was nothing bigger yeah that was
the vision of what hollywood was
and you guys tapped into hollywood in a
way that nobody else could you made
everything about hollywood uh you made
it you made it real you made the people
and the things that you hear about you
made the girls you made the parties it's
relatable it was accessible and it was
certainly the most the greatest wish for
filming absolutely for your guys and
your crew absolutely um and then i think
as as you understood okay this is based
off of mark and his crew and then i
finally [ __ ] work with you
and i meet your crew
holy [ __ ]
mark's [ __ ] friend
circle his foundation when i honestly
got to meet these guys
i was so blown away
that it was real
you